there are certain clarifying moments in
political discourse moments that
demonstrate just where the various
parties stand never has the gap been so
obvious as this last week on Friday the
left declared the world was in imminent
peril the problem President Trump will
definitely altogether meaningless Paris
climate Accord a worldwide agreement
requesting non-binding commitments from
signatories about future carbon
emissions cuts the hysteria was palpable
suddenly debunked whether prognosticator
Al Gore found himself in prime
television swats jabbering about the end
of the world House Minority Leader Nancy
Pelosi she gaveled about how Trump was
dishonouring God no word on her abortion
on demand position from the Holy One
blessed be he The Huffington Post ran a
headline showing the world in flames the
Mayor of London Sadiq Khan released a
statement the moaning Trump's decision
meanwhile the right shrug it pointed out
the agreement didn't really do much
anyway it didn't bind China and India to
any serious commitments the Senate had
not passed any enabling legislation
perhaps non-governmental alternatives
should be considered before diving
headlong into empowerment of the
regulatory state to fight a rising
temperature over the next century on
Saturday a group of Islamic terrorists
drop a van into a crowd on London Bridge
and then jumped out of the vehicle and
started stabbing people in surrounding
establishments Isis claimed
responsibility the right immediately
labeled the attacks yet another example
of Islamic extremism on March linking
them with a Manchester terror attack
President Trump took to Twitter to
denounce the terror attacks and call for
an end politically correct policies as
well as some for his travel ban
conservatives on both sides of the
Atlantic complains about leftist
multiculturalism creating room for
Islamic terror growth meanwhile what
shrug Sally cone Swede about the glories
of political correctness
Paul Krugman compared being killed in a
terrorist attack being killed by a drunk
driver Democrats complained about
President Trump's attacks on Khan who
was vizier geing Londoners to stay calm
after panicking about global warming
just a few days ago what explains this
gap between left and right the Left
believes that human beings are
inherently good and that only
environment defines whether they will
act in evil fashion that's why senator
Bernie Sanders articulated in 2016 that
global warming was the spur to terrorism
it's why the Obama administration
routinely suggested that poverty causes
terrorism external circumstances dictate
the morality of individual actors that's
also why the Left argues we shouldn't
hold people responsible for their
actions as a general rule instead we
should reshape society the right on the
and believes that human beings are
capable of evil all on their own that's
why they see the rise of radical Islam
as more of a problem than global warming
good people won't kill each other just
because the world is getting warmer they
will if they begin to believe evil
ideologies or support those who do the
gap is not bridgeable it goes to the
nature of humanity and our perception of
that nature but it's requiring a greater
and greater strain these days to blame
anybody but individual human beings in
free Western societies for their own
descent into evil I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show all right tons
to get to today I want to talk about
what we really should be talking about
and then I want to talk about what the
media is instead talking about of course
these Comey hearings and then NSA had
Mike Rogers is in front of the Senate
Intelligence Committee as well as Dan
coats D the Director of National
Intelligence both of them testifying
right now
we'll get to all of that and bring you
the latest updates but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
ProFlowers so I've been using ProFlowers
for years long before they were a
sponsor whenever I go out of town I try
to send my wife flowers from abroad and
ProFlowers of the way that I do it they
always send fresh flowers it's always
great whenever there's an issue they
make it right immediately we've had
broke it we had a broken vase one time
and they sent a brand new vase right
then and there
right now ProFlowers has a special offer
just for our listeners you get $10 off
your purchase of $29 or more this deal
works best on best selling gifts like
their 100 blooms bouquet a dozen red
roses or even their totally unique plant
gifts to get that great deal go to
proflowers.com right now and enter Ben's
show at checkout that's Ben's show at
checkout Pro flowers bouquets they're
guaranteed fresh for seven days or
they'll refund all of your money they
have a seven septons that the flowers
are always awesome and their website is
really easy to use you can schedule your
delivery ahead of time for any date you
want and get back to you and get back to
that day Pro flowers is a no-brainer
gift for birthday or an anniversary for
Father's Day which is coming up every
occasion or an occasion at all Pro
flowers just fantastic I use it made my
marriage better because when you show
love then your spouse shows one for you
as well proflowers.com promo code Ben's
show 10 dollars off any purchase of
twenty nine dollars or more so
significant discount there plus if you
use the promo code Ben show they know
that we sent you which means they
continue advertising with us which means
we can continue to bring you the show so
Ben's show and go to proflowers.com
use that promo code Ben she'll get that
ten bucks off for any purchase of $29
for more okay so let's start with what
people should be talking about today
what people should be talking about
today is there is a global threat of
Islamic terror there's an Islamic terror
attack in Canada over the weekend
everybody ignored it there's a global
there was an Islamic terror attack Isis
actually is now basically at war with
Iran and Iran is now blaming Saudi
Arabia so the chances of a Middle
Eastern conflagration are growing
exponentially meanwhile Saudi Arabia is
in the middle of a firefight now a
political firefight anyway with the
nation of Qatar Qatar is a backdoor
terror supporter and they have in for a
long time and now see Arabia is posing
itself in opposition to them so things
are shaping up for what could actually
turn into a hot conflict in the Middle
East between Iran and Saudi Arabia or
Saudi Arabia and Qatar things could get
very ugly very quickly over there and
meanwhile all of that is resulting in an
increase in terror abroad Isis is trying
to demonstrate that it still has muscle
so there have been terrorist attacks I
say in Britain in Toronto there's one in
the Philippines and the London Mayor was
asked by the things my Piers Morgan
actually what exactly he's doing to stop
terrorism and basically said we can't do
much merica okay I can't follow for
other people what I can do is make sure
my wife sees because we can do those
make sure that the resources for the
police and the expert why do you
instruct the police why can't he call
Cressida dick right now well I think
every one of those people after you come
back from a war zone who's in London I
want them followed and he has no answer
for that he starts to kind of
about the answer is that he can but he
won't because the fact is we are
deploying our law enforcement resources
in the West in exactly the wrong way we
have used political correct politically
correct ways of doing it you know people
wonder why it is that the intelligence
community has these blanket surveillance
tools disease for all Americans one of
the reasons is political correctness if
we weren't politically correct then we'd
be using all of our law enforcement
resources at the hottest spot we still
are using a disproportionate amount but
we have to pretend that we're not so
instead we decide it's more important to
surveil everyone equally and so we have
these giant metadata programs instead of
focusing in on say people who are coming
back from Syria or people who are going
to a hobby funded mosque
so defunded mosques it's a huge mistake
meanwhile Democrats of course are not
focusing on the threat of Islamic terror
at all they are trying to continue to
play identity politics they're trying to
say that Republicans are evil and
terrible not because Republicans are bad
at protecting you from terrorism they're
evil and terrible because they're racist
and sexist and bigoted and homophobic so
Andrew Cuomo who is the governor of New
York who should theoretically be
spending a lot of his time focused on
the terror threats in places like New
York City instead he's spending his time
preparing for its 2020 run by going
around saying that President Trump hates
immigrants and just wants to deport
people so he should deport Andrew Cuomo
you want to deport immigrants start with
me because I'm an immigrant well if only
we could Andrew Cuomo be you're an
American citizen so we cannot do that
nor should we but it is something the
fact is the Democrats are seeking to
avoid the real discussion which is what
do we do about radical Islamic terror
what they are really wanting to focus on
is of course these hearings that are
happening on the hill right now so
they're breaking pieces of news last
night surrounding James Comey the former
FBI director and President Trump and the
big question from all of this because
today as I say we have the National
Security Advisor will be the head of the
National Security Agency rather Mike
Rogers testifying on the hill there were
reports that Rogers had been asked by
Trump to pressure Comey to drop the
Trump Russia investigation into Flint
there was also a report that Trump had
Afghan Coates is the head of the
Director of National Intelligence to
pressure call me to back off of my Flynn
the former national security adviser
when those reports were all coming out
in the last couple of weeks they are
testifying today on the hill you also
have the you have combing himself is
testifying on the hill tomorrow so I
wanna bring you all the updates about
this but the only question that matters
here the only question that really
matters is did President Trump in any
way attempt to hamper the investigation
into Trump campaign Russia connections
did he attend that that's the big
question in all of this did he attempt
to do that did he attempt to pressure
Coates did he attempt to pressure Rogers
did he attempt to pressure Jeff Sessions
did he attempt to pressure Comey before
he fired him was it was any of this
designed to actually shut down the
investigation now if you're on the Left
you got to be saying well sure of course
it looks like now according to these
reports he asked Coates to tell Co me to
back off he asked Rodgers to tell Co me
to back off
he asked Coates to disown the Russian
dossier we talked about several months
ago this intelligence dossier about
Trump and Russia much of which turned
out to be false and close refused to do
it
he fired Co me if you're on the Left you
have to be saying well yeah I mean
there's pressure everywhere and to be
fair if the situation were reversed if
he had Barack Obama and Barack Obama's
IRS head were being investigated and she
went up and she testified that Barack
Obama did not put any pregnant and yet
some secret conversations with her in
their reports that he had asked her to
target 501c3 charities and the question
was did he pressure you to push 501c3
charities that were conservative out the
back door we would all be saying well
why would we trust her answer that's the
left is saying today but again no
evidence no evidence of any of this and
no evidence of serious pressure being
brought everyone has testified now
according to Rogers today he just
testified moments ago that he has not
felt pressure from the Trump
administration to do anything illegal
code said basically the same thing
they're giving a little bit shifty
answers in some areas they're they're
saying things like I feel it's
inappropriate to answer I don't know if
I legally can answer but regardless of
that there's still no evidence that
Trump actually pressured so there's two
ways of reading Trump's behavior in all
of this and I want to go through what
the reports are about Trump's behavior
and then I'll explain the two reads on
the behavior so the Washington Post
reported last night this is all in prep
run-up for the for the Comey hearing
become a hearing tomorrow is what
Democrats are looking forward to they
think the Comey is going to come forward
and Comey is going to say the following
he's going to get up and he's going to
say
president Trump met with me he asked me
to kill the Trump Russian investigation
I refused to do so he fired me that's
the narrative Democrats are hoping for
that's not the narrative they're likely
to get but in preparation for that
narrative the bars in DC are opening up
tomorrow apparently and they're putting
the Comey hearings on TV CBS is
broadcasting it network time which as I
mentioned yesterday is just insane when
they have broadcast Lois Lerner's
testimony on network time with a
broadcast Eric Holder's testimony on
network time when they broadcast Hillary
Clinton's Benghazi testimony on network
time of course not this is evidence of
tremendous tremendous Nydia bias but the
media are
hot and bothered about this so they're
leaking incessantly about Comey and
about coats and about Rogers and about
all of us so here's the Washington Post
report last night they say quote the
president complained to the he met with
CIA director Mike Pompeo and DNI Dan
Coates they attended a briefing at the
White House he pulled them aside and
told everybody else to leave and then
quote the president started complaining
about the FBI investigation and commis
handling of it said officials familiar
with the account Coates gave two
associates two days earlier Comey had
confirmed in a congressional hearing the
bureau was probing whether Trump's
campaign coordinated with Russia during
the 2016 race after the encounter Coates
discussed the conversation with other
officials and decided that intervening
with Comey as Trump had suggested would
be inappropriate according to officials
who spoke on condition of anonymity to
discuss sensitive internal matters so
I'm not sure where the illegality lies
the president can say anything he wants
but it's not obstruction of justice
unless he actively does something to
obstruct justice and if I went to Dan
Coates and I said and Dan I'd appreciate
you drop this investigation it wouldn't
mean anything if the president does it
it doesn't really mean anything either
maybe it's a backdoor sort of pressure
but it's not obvious that that is
pressure rising from level of
obstruction of justice is it just
possible that Trump is so annoyed with
the Trump Russia investigation because
he himself note that he's innocent that
he's saying off-the-cuff silly things to
people my fear is that that's what best
fits with the evidence not the Trump is
some sort of mastermind attempting in
its own Ian fashion to quash the
investigation but that Trump is so
frustrated with Comey and with the Trump
Russian investigation that he's angry
everyone there's a report today these
angry at Jeff Sessions okay Jeff
Sessions of course is his Attorney
General and one of the more solid kind
of populist nationalist in the
administration if you are somebody who
likes Trump's agenda Jeff Sessions is
your man I mean Jeff Sessions is the guy
who's anti-immigration Jeff Sessions is
the guy who is in favor of harsher
restrictions on immigration and and
harsher enforcement of crime Jeff
Sessions is somebody you want to see
stay in other words if you are a fan of
Trump but now there's tension between
Trump and sessions apparently according
to ABC News Justice Department
spokesperson Sarah it's core Flores
would not comment when asked by ABC News
his sessions had threatened or offered
to resign additionally White House press
secretary Sean Spicer yesterday would
not confirm
from still has confidence in sessions
saying I said I have not had a
discussion with him on the question I
don't if I had if I haven't had a
discussion about a subject I tend not to
speak about it which is a pretty weird
way of answering a question about
whether the president has confidence in
his own attorney general sort of this
language that was being mirrored by Sean
Spicer before Comey was fired so clearly
there's tension between sessions and
Trump so in other words Trump is angry
at everyone that the Trump Russia
investigation won't just die not because
he's guilty but because Trump thinks
he's innocent Trump says I didn't do
anything I know I didn't do anything and
that's really plausible that Trump
didn't do anything even if man afford
even if Manta for Paul Manafort is
former campaign manager did something
even if Carter page his former foreign
policy adviser did something even if
Mike Flynn it did something that is not
evidence that Trump himself did
something and he can sense that Trump
has a divide in his own mind between the
Trump campaign and Trump himself and by
the way if you're Mike Flynn and you're
cutting some sort of corrupt deal with
the Russians or Paul mana Ford you're
the Russians the last person you would
tell is Donald Trump for two reasons one
Trump would likely fire you and two even
if Trump didn't fire you you're now
making him privy well the three reasons
- you're making him privy to information
that could get him impeached if he ever
was discovered to have been involved in
this and three if you tell Trump there's
a good shot that Trump will say
something dumb about it on national TV
and get everybody in trouble so the
reality here is that Trump probably is
innocent Trump probably is irritated and
Trump probably is going around saying to
everyone he can find can you please stop
this because it's annoying me that I
think is the account that best fits with
the evidence but that's not what
Democrats are saying I'm going to get to
that in just a second the over the skis
nature of this the Democrats really
pushing a narrative that doesn't exist a
narrative that is far over the top and
they're going to continue pushing it and
it's up to Trump how to tamp that down
there's away from to do it we'll talk
about that in a second but first I want
to talk about our advertisers over at
Realty shares so if you're somebody
who's interested in investing in real
estate but you've never really looked
into investing in real estate you think
you don't have enough money to invest in
real estate Realty shares is the place
for you what they do is they actually
diversify investments big investments
among people who are smaller investors
it is not an offering of securities
private investments are highly illiquid
and risky and not suitable for all
investors test performance is not
indicative of future results securities
offered to a crowd
and investors through North Capitol
private securities member finra s ipeec
but reality shares calm is demolishing
the walls between you and real estate
investing you don't need billions or
millions or even tens of thousands of
bucks to invest in vetted real estate
assets with Realty shares hundreds of
people invest fractionally right you
reduce the cost of your initial
investment their deals are vetted they
are curated by industry professionals
they underwrite and perform due
diligence so you don't have to source
these investment opportunities yourself
you have to waste all your time doing
that instead you basically have a list
of investments in which you can take
part and then you go to real see shares
and you invest it is free to sign up and
browse the investments getting set up
takes just a few minutes and then you
can manage and invest straight from your
phone or computer through their simple
and secure online process all it takes
is five thousand bucks to make an
investment there are no hidden fees and
listen if you want to build wealth
there's no better way to do it than
investing in real estate if you make
$200,000 a year you may qualify find out
today at realty shares dot-com /femme
that's realty shares dot-com / planet by
the way if you use Realty shares com /
ben-ari al t Y shares come / Ben then
you get 100 bucks toward your first
investment close to 100 thousand
investors nationwide are using Realty
shares sixty million dollars in
principal has been returned to investors
Realty shares worked and again it is the
best way for you to diversify your
holdings and you want to make sure that
you that you comply with all the
restrictions and then you should
definitely become an investor in Realty
shares go today to realty shares com /
Ben again $100 toward your first
investment is what you get re alt y
shares calm / Ben okay so the the fact
is that the Democrats are trying to
over-read the situation the Democrats
are going with the Trump was colluding
now Trump is covering it up and you can
see the people who they are trotting out
to say things like this so the first
person they're trotting out is James
clapper James clapper was the Director
of National Intelligence under Barack
Obama he's appointed by Obama and
clapper is not an honest person he's the
person who lied in front of Congress
when he said that people were not being
surveilled essentially by the National
Security Agency that was not true now
James clapper was doing a speech to the
National Press Club in Australia and
here is what he had to say about the
Trump administration the subsequent
actions here
sense of intelligence with the Russians
and compromising its source reflect
either ignorance or disrespect and
either is very problematic
similarly the whole episode with the
firing of Jim Comey a distinguished
public servant apart from the egregious
inexcusable manner in which it was
conducted reflect complete disregard for
the independence and autonomy of the
Federal Bureau of Investigation our
premier law enforcement organization
shamelessly some positive right there
for a second when he says that it
reflects a lack of respect for the
autonomy at the FBI what he is implying
there in the Trump is invading the
autonomy of the FBI meaning that he is
attempting to cram down his view of the
Trump Russia investigation on the FBI no
evidence has been provided of that Trump
has every right to fire James Comey who
was is and will be an incompetent
bloviating blowhard here is James
clapper continuing know that I think you
compare the two that Watergate tales
really in my view as compared to what we
were confronting now okay that's insane
Watergate is not pale in comparison for
two reasons one there was an underlying
crime in Watergate
we know there was a break-in at the
Watergate Hotel we know that it was
subordinates of President Nixon who
conducted that break-in and we know that
President Nixon attempted to cover it up
obstruct justice and fire people here we
don't know that there's an underlying
crime here we don't know that Trump was
actually trying to obstruct when he
fired
Comey and there's been from by all the
available actual evidence that we've
seen no one can provide a shred of
evidence other than accusations that
there's been an actual attempt to shut
down the investigation in fact the
people who are key people like rod
Rosenstein people like Rogers people
like the people like dni Coates
all of these people have said there is
no actual intervention into the Trump
Russia investigation so how can you sit
there and claim this is worse than
Watergate how can you claim that he
can't because he's political hack but
again I just want to point out that if
you're on the Left what you need in
order to keep this thing alive is you
need more smoke so the left will push it
smoke
what you really need up here the left is
unique Trump to continue to fulminate
you need Trump to continue to get angry
and sweet things because the more Trump
tweets the more he fulminates the more
he acts out the more he asks people to
shut down investigations the more he
tells people can you please leave this
alone the more irritated Trump gets more
volatile he gets more volatile he gets
the morning temps to say innately not
smart things to people about an
investigation that may not be
obstruction of justice but they give
hints of obstruction of justice if you
are a member of the left so the best
thing that Trump can do right now is to
take it easy that'd be the best thing
the Trump concern I'm gonna talk about
what exactly Trump can do to tamp all
this down he I think starting to do some
of this but he's going to need to not
live tweet commis testimony tomorrow to
do the rest but in order for you to hear
what the strategy ought to be and how
Republicans are responding to all of
this you need to go over to daily wire
comm right now and become a subscriber
for $8 a month you too can subscribe at
daily wire comm that monthly
subscription will get you the rest of
the Ben Shapiro show lodging be part of
the mailbag which we are going to be
doing on Fridays we're now a five-day
weeks show you're going to be
contributing to our new studios we have
new studios that are that are going to
be premiering next week you know we've
been we've been basically doing this
from the inside apparently of a Russian
- up for the last year and a half but we
are going to actually be moving over to
some beautiful new studios in the next
few days which is really really exciting
you can part of that as well
over at Daley wire.com and if you become
an annual subscriber right now not only
do you get all of those things but you
also get a free signed copy of the new
book by me and my father say it's so
Papa Dada me and the 2005 Chicago White
Sox championship season you don't have
to be a Chicago White Sox and to enjoy
the book if you're a baseball fan you
will enjoy the book it's a lot of fun
it's about fathers and sons and what was
really tough here actually for my family
but my dad and I spent the year watching
these baseball games and writing about
it and it was just a blast and I think
the books a lot of fun to read it
actually kind of moving I think great
Father's Day gift go over and become an
annual subscriber right now over at
daily wire come get a free signed copy
and we will send it direct to you and
you can give it to your pops really good
present so daily Wired icon become a
subscriber or if you just want to listen
to the show later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and make sure that we've
review overnight Tunes we always
appreciate it this is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you